a popular las vegas attraction is the
focus of tomorrow's new episode of
undercover boss and it's right here of
course on cbs that's right the staff at
the fremont street experience were able
to show the ceo what it takes to run the
operations of one of the busiest streets
in the entire country christian casares
joining us live from the fremont street
experience with a behind the scenes look
hey guys that's right well ceo andrew
simon tells me there is no better way
than to showcase what the fremont street
experience is all about he also tells me
that this is a great way to learn about
the jobs that help keep this place
running and find ways for improvement
ceo andrew simon getting a first hand
look at what it's like to work the
fremont street experience for the latest
episode of cbs's undercover boss at the
end of the day it was to learn more
about what can we do to make people's
jobs easier from the zip line do a lot
of people
not make it yeah a lot of people do quit
because they can't handle it to trash
pickup oh my god
for the show simon went undercover as
ken masters a week-long production shot
last summer so many people think this is
all staged and everything else i did not
know what i was doing and who i was
doing it with until i got there born and
raised in long island simon learned all
sorts of jobs at his parents summer camp
now as ceo he admits it's hard work
going up there and being up there for at
least 10 hours and trying to clean
garbage and do other things on top of
that canopy that was the most grueling
that assignment high above the crowds
we're about to clear trash 100 feet
above the ground
okay okay to scraping gum off the floor
am i going fast enough i think you're
taking a little little too long yeah we
have to move okay no one recognize me as
far as i know jokes aside simon says his
biggest task has been stepping into the
role as ceo in the middle of a pandemic
i was frankly a little bit scared but i
was really excited about the opportunity
to make the street better than it's ever
been
all right back out here live you can see
that there's promotions all over this
area now simon tells me this experience
also helped him to learn more and
connect more with his employees and the
hard work that they bring every single
day again this venue has been around for
26 years and about 25 million people
come here each year again undercover
boss airs tomorrow night right here on
channel eight christian casa is live
local now